we are very possibly living in the era
of the greatest Supreme Court bench in
American history
that has been true that we are very
possibly in that era since last year's
decision in Dobbs which overruled the
single worst decision in American
history Roe v Wade
but the claim has now gotten some strong
backup since yesterday the Supreme Court
of the United States struck down
affirmative action racial discrimination
in college admissions and as a cherry on
top
the exact losing party
was the liberal lunatics over at Harvard
that was just that just a little L for
Harvard was just a right on top of this
otherwise totally beautiful case already
totally beautiful case the case was
four students for fair admissions
Incorporated versus president and
fellows of Harvard College and the Court
ruled six to three that race-based
admissions programs at Harvard and UNC
violate the equal protection Clause of
the 14th Amendment chief justice Roberts
joined the conservatives and wrote for
the court quote eliminating racial
discrimination means eliminating all of
it
I know
the conservatives are supposed to whine
and complain and constantly lament the
end of the world
but this Supreme Court
thanks to three judges
appointed by one president one president
who was improbably elected after all the
Smart Set political Geniuses said Hope
was lost he didn't have a chance 99
chance the Democrat was going to win
well this Supreme Court it exists only
as a result of all those things
happening
has officially and significantly changed
the chorus of American history for the
better just when conservatives were
inclined to give up hope we remember an
important lesson heading into Fourth of
July weekend a verse of a very important
song that very often gets left out of
the singing oh thus be it ever when free
men shall stand between their left home
and the war's desolation blessed with
Victory and peace May the heaven rescued
land praise the power that hath made and
preserved us a nation then conquer we
must when our cause it is just and this
be our motto in God is our trust and the
Star-Spangled Banner in Triumph shall
wave or the land of the free and the
home of the brave I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
it's a good day folks it's good we got
to celebrate the wins when we get them
and to celebrate we'll do something a
little special and fun at the end of
something that I usually only reserve
for the creme de La Creme the Inner
Circle the real you know
the real members we're gonna do it at
the end of the show it's fake headline
Friday we'll get to that in just a bit
first though this case students for fair
admissions Incorporated versus president
fellows of Harvard College what is this
group this is a group that said that
they were unfairly discriminated against
in the admissions processes at Harvard
and UNC
as the group pointed to the high test
scores of Asian students and white
applicants who were rejected if the case
were only brought by white students it
would have gone nowhere because we live
at a time
well I guess this has just changed we
live in a time where you had widespread
day your a racial discrimination against
white people and we still live in a time
where the only group that you are
allowed to and encouraged socially to
attack and insult and malign and mock is
white people
so if it had only been white students
who were affected here I don't think the
case really would have gone very far but
the libs made a big mistake they got a
little sloppy and they discriminated
against Asians too and Asians can claim
the mantle of discriminated against
oppressed minority and so this exposed
some of the incoherence of the
affirmative action regime after this
Civil Rights Movement the black civil
rights movement in the 1960s a lot of
other groups on the left realized that
they could try to mimic the civil rights
movement of black people who have a
unique role in American history because
of the existence of slavery and the long
experience of black people in America
they realized they could kind of mimic
that and try to get their own ends to
the point that today you you even have
people who have various sexual desires
and identities and all this kind of
nonsense claiming to be the new civil
rights movement and this didn't really
work when one of the arguments
for affirmative action was that you need
to protect these poor grieved racial
minorities and then you've got a poor
aggrieved racial minority that says wait
you're discriminating against us too
because we're Asians and we work very
hard and we have high IQs and we're
doing well on these tests but we're not
being allowed in while people from other
racial groups who have lower test scores
are being allowed in in our place
because of racial favoritism in the in
the schools okay so you get it this case
overrules a previous case grudder the
Bollinger this was a case that was
decided 23 years ago I think it was I
think it was a 2003 case and at the time
that grudder was decided which upheld
affirmative action in college admissions
Sandra Day O'Connor the nominally
Conservative Republican appointed
Justice who often sided with the libs
she said we expect that 25 years from
now the use of racial preferences will
no longer be necessary so already built
in to the upholding of affirmative
action was this idea that it's going to
be time limited and where do you get
that principle from in the Constitution
you don't and it was just the Supreme
Court with the libs and the squish
conservatives shooting from the hip but
now we're almost exactly 25 years later
and the court says okay time's up it
wasn't just Sandra Day O'Connor who
though a squish was still appointed by a
republican by Ronald Reagan but it was
even the libs it was even the liberal
icons you know Ruth Bader Ginsburg at
the time of Greta V Bollinger upholding
affirmative action she still said that
it can't be used forever but it's useful
for the time being to give us the racial
outcomes that we want in society
Justice Thomas at the time made a really
important point that that I haven't
heard a lot of people talk about but it
shows you why these schools are so
insistent up on upholding affirmative
action they were insistent on it not
just because they're liberal ideologues
and they hate white people and they want
to help other racial groups get an
unfair advantage over white people or
whatever it's also because these schools
want to maintain their Prestige and they
recognize that as racial diversity and
inclusion and equity and whatever all
the rest of these ideologies become
important in American life that in order
to continue to train the elite the
people who inevitably will become part
of the elite such so long as this
ideology predominates they need to
bring in more people of these racial
groups that are not doing as well on the
tests and if test scores are the only
thing that matter are are not going to
be admitted to the college in very high
numbers so they're trying to maintain
their Prestige and their hold on
American public life
Thomas went even further Clarence Thomas
in the in the grudder case and he said
that the schools have to pick high
standards or diversity that's that if
they're going to exalt high standards
then they need to stop playing favorites
with the races if they're going to exalt
racial diversity or whatever sexual
diversity or all the other kinds of
diversity for diversity's sake then they
need to stop pretending that they're
they're valuing high standards it's one
or the other they're mutually opposed
here because
even if you say well there obviously
there are plenty of black people who do
very well on tests and who will do very
well in these schools I mean just
Justice Thomas would be a great example
of this it's about the principle that
you're enshrining is college admissions
primarily about high standards or is it
primarily about diversity and ideology
so
today the Supreme Court says affirmative
action gone in college admissions and
don't forget the Supreme Court reads the
polls Supreme Court reads the newspapers
and a majority of Americans 62 percent
overwhelming need not just Republicans
not just white people but a wide
smattering of American people oppose
race-based College admissions
because they all know it seems really
really unfair so now we've got
the opinion we got The Descent we've got
two dueling opinions in the case one
opinion one to send
from the two black members of the
Supreme Court offering very different
visions of race and affirmative action
in the Constitution which we'll get to
in one second first though before I talk
to you about that I need to talk to you
about talking to your friends and your
family which is why you got to check out
pure talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com Knowles I am a very
Discerning partner okay
in my love life my social life in my
professional life I'm Discerning about
the partners that I choose and a company
that I'm proud to stand behind is that
company spread to stand behind us and
our country and offers a great service
is pure talk better announced with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless partner of
the daily wire but that's not the only
reason Pure Talk also happens to be the
most Dependable 5G Network in the U.S
they're a top tier provider and a
fraction of the cost of those other woke
companies that don't care about you or
your beliefs mix and match your plans to
fit every person in your family choose
from talk text and 5G data for just 20
bucks a month all the way up to
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot for
55 a month you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you instead go to puretalk.com Knowles
you'll get great coverage and save while
you're doing it puretalk.com Knowles
save an additional 50 off your first
month because they value you
puretalk.com Knowles
puretalk Wireless for Americans by
Americans the libs
love Justice katanji Jackson
she's the new one she's the Biden
appointee and katanji Jackson
feisty they like her because she's a
woman they like her because she's black
they like her for all these kind of more
superficial Skin Deep reasons sexual
reasons
and they like her because she's
extremely radical she didn't know what a
woman was she couldn't Define a woman at
her confirmation hearings so I didn't
have very high hopes for her dissent in
this case and my low expectations were
proven correct
here's what she wrote this this is the
part portion of katanji Jackson's
descent that all the libs are sharing
around she said quote with let them eat
cake obliviousness today the majority
pulls the rip cord and announces color
blindness for all by legal Fiat but
deeming race Irrelevant in law does not
make it so in life
and having so detached itself from this
country's actual past and present
experiences the court has now been lured
into interfering with the crucial work
that UNC and other institutions of
Higher Learning
are doing to solve America's real world
problems no one benefits from ignorance
although formal race linked legal
barriers are gone race still matters to
the lived experiences and it's just a
blah blah blah lived experience you know
it's basically my friends Spencer
Cleveland pointed this out he said going
in here
the students bringing the case and the
group bringing the case on behalf of the
students saying hey we don't want to be
discriminated against just because we're
Asian or white they had the law on their
side they had philosophy on their side
they had morality on their side they had
the opinion of the conservative judges
and they said they had the opinion of
very prominent liberal judges and they
said they had they had a pretty good
case and on the on the pro-race
Discrimination side of this case they
had
diversity is our strength the lived
experiences of the racial oppression and
it's just that didn't that was not a
legally persuasive
View and it hasn't persuaded the
majority of the American people the
funniest part of of Justice Jackson's
very silly descent is that first line
of of this section
let them eat cake obliviousness because
what that term does is reveals Justice
Jackson's obliviousness we know she's
oblivious she doesn't know what a woman
is but she's also oblivious to history
because that phrase let them eat cake is
a phrase attributed to Marie Antoinette
when when Marie Antoinette supposedly
was told that the peasants didn't have
bread to eat you said let them eat cake
let them meet brioche but it's a total
fabrication it was made up the line
actually predates Marie Antoinette no
great princess said it it's just fake
it's just total fake news and the libs
fall into their fake news all the time
and they are oblivious to history
and biology
philosophy and the law apparently and so
it's over what does Justice Thomas say
in response to this he answers Jackson
he says accordingly Justice Jackson's
race-infused worldview Falls flat at
each step individuals are the sum of
their unique experiences challenges and
accomplishments what matters is not the
barriers they face but how they choose
to confront them
and their race is not to blame for
everything good or bad that happens in
their lives a contrary myopic worldview
based on individual skin color to the
total exclusion of their personal
choices is nothing short of racial
determinism so true two different
visions of race one conservative from
Justice Thomas one liberal from Justice
Jackson Thomas is a Catholic you can you
can just tell this in his writing in the
way he speaks Justice Thomas says the
Christian view here or specifically a
very Catholic view of the world Justice
Jackson again her religion is just
racial grievance and liberalism and
whining and pride Thomas's hard work
humility gratitude Jackson's Envy
resentment Pride anger Wrath
all the stuff we associate with the libs
and
as has happened now a couple times from
the Supreme Court recently and what
happens rarely in our political life
the good side one really really great
stuff speaking of Freedom a big debate
has broken out over whether Elon Musk
should ban the word CIS c-i-s from
Twitter
and it's still raging I mentioned this
on the show a few days ago but it's
still raging and Brad Palumbo my debate
partner from the University of
Pittsburgh and Brad pinch hit after the
transgender identifying Professor that I
was supposed to debate on issues of
gender and sex dropped out at the last
minute because he felt that he couldn't
do the debate so Brad comes in and uh
Brad is a
self-described libertarian and he says
Elon Musk is the worst free speech hero
ever
and uh that's because you should be able
to say anything on Twitter and if you
don't this is absolutely terrible
and of course Brad is wrong here and I
wrote a book about how what Elon is
doing is fabulous the book is called
speechless controlling words controlling
wines number number one National
bestseller thank you very much this is
one of the most encouraging things that
Elon has done because it shows a
sophistication not just a sophomoric
very Elementary vision of politics that
is based on Modern incoherent ideologies
that have never been put into practice
effectively anywhere in the world
throughout all of human history but he's
recognizing that there's Nuance here we
support Free Speech but when we support
Free Speech we're supporting a tradition
not something in the abstract floating
in outer space but a real tradition with
exclusions exclusions like threats like
obscenity like fighting words like fraud
like all of these sorts of things and uh
I'm Elon is a great figure in technology
and business but a lot of guys when they
dip their toes from their areas of
expertise into politics they sometimes
demonstrate a great deal of ignorance
Elon here I think is demonstrating a lot
of sophistication and you see it
actually
in the case of the affirmative action
decision
the whole thing is about standards and
the affirmative action case asks what
kind of standards are we going to have
in this country
and so far what the judges are saying
now is we're going to have something
closer to a meritocracy
and before that on affirmative action
you're gonna have something closer to a
racial hierarchy with black people and
Native Americans and I don't know at the
top of it and then maybe uh Hispanics
they go a little bit lower and then
Asians and white people at the bottom
and if you're a member of a favorite
race you get special treatment and if
you're a member of a disfavored race
you're the scum of the earth and and
you're going to be discriminated against
that was the view that predominated for
the last
many decades you know four or five
decades maybe six decades now I guess
now what happened before that a lot of
conservatives want to be a little
simplistic about this and say well
before affirmative action you just had a
pure meritocracy but that's not quite
true and we don't just have quite a pure
meritocracy now because there are other
factors at Play
there is
legacy admissions
don't favor the highest test scores they
favor people with a tie to the
university the pure meritocrats say we
need to get rid of legacy admissions but
that's not a conservative point of view
you want some continuity you want people
to say no my family has had a connection
to this institution not just a college
but maybe a church maybe a neighborhood
maybe a community organization maybe
maybe a maybe a senate seat for goodness
sakes you know tradition and continuity
and
uh the kind of experience that you don't
just learn out of a textbook or learn on
your own for the first time but that is
imbued into you and your family from
birth
that's a pretty conservative thing we
like tradition we like we like things
outside of pure rationalistic book
learning
okay there's that there is
the essay
and the college essay is supposed to
figure out how well you think and how
well you write
but that personal statement also says
something about who you are what your
experiences are probably now the people
who do want to discriminate against
white people uh in college admissions
they will just increase the importance
of the personal essay and they will use
that as a way to say okay if the person
I indicates that he is not white then
we'll give him a little bit more of an
advantage here
um so that's that's not just a pure
meritocracy and before affirmative
action that that's certainly true there
were inherited privileges uh obviously
there was a different kind of racial
discrimination in the country and all
sorts of other
all sorts of other little prejudices and
all sorts of other little ineffable
complications of life that made things a
little bit different at the founding of
the country uh my friend sirab Amari
pointed this out on Twitter just
yesterday the Jeffersonian ideal which
you might say was a pure meritocracy
wasn't quite a pure meritocracy it was
this idea that you have a lot of Yeoman
Farmers that you'd have a lot of people
who had their own property in their own
land but not Grand Estates just you know
relatively
more modest Republican lowercase R types
of land so there are all these different
views and different
standards and and I think we just need
to be aware of that all the time because
we can fall into the same trap of saying
no the absolutely totally purely
objective neutral standard is
meritocracy now that's not really
totally neutral either that's an
ideology too
the totally absolutely free unregulated
free market that's the neutral thing no
that that's a standard too and some
people might object to that statement so
we need to be a little bit more
forthright about it this is a big step
in the right direction we need to be
even clearer moving forward there's this
is such big news I had a lot of other
things that I really wanted to get to
today but we've got a lot to do we've
got fake headline Friday we've got the
mailbag that we have to get to I guess
the only I'm going to give you a little
tease and maybe we'll try to get to it
next week apparently Joe Biden is open
to psychedelics which you might think
Joe Biden's psychiatric condition right
now couldn't possibly get any worse so
maybe taking a bunch of hallucinogenic
drugs it might not improve things but it
might not make them worse but apparently
according to Joe Biden's brother
Joe is open to psychedelics so I'll
leave you for the Fourth of July weekend
on that that image of Joe just tripping
out on shrooms and LSD maybe we'll get
to it next week uh first as you're
grilling out this weekend though you got
to make sure that propane tank is full
so while you got to check out cinch
right now go to cinch.com use promo code
Knowles Fourth of July is upon us with
many wonderful family gatherings popping
up the last thing that you need when
hosting your family is turning on the
grill and being out of propane
that would be terrible that's where our
friends at cinch come in cinches propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
on your schedule they do not require any
long-term commitment or subscription
plus deliveries completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere the perfect summer night would
not be complete without cinch go online
to cinch.com or download the Cinch app
to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knowles cinch.com or
download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls to get your first tank exchange
for just 10 bucks this is a limited time
offer you must live within a cinch
service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com right now slash offer for
details and make sure that you sign up
summer is here baby it's the fourth of
July do not even have to think about
your propane tanksinch.com promo code
Knowles we're doing something a little
different today folks I usually just
Reserve this for the creme de La Creme
the but
you may have noticed over the last week
or so there are more restrictions
imposed on this show
on one of the big Tech platforms and so
I I'm not going to change really what
I'm saying I'm not going to censor
myself I'm not going to lie I'm not
going to do any of that so we're just
going to have to take out little parts
of the show in order to not have the
whole Channel completely nuked and the
episode's fully removed and we're trying
to be innocent as a serpent and sorry
we're trying to be innocent as a Dev and
why is this a serpent you don't want to
be innocent as a serpent and why is it
as a Dev that's probably the worst of
all worlds but if you want the full show
then you got to go head on over and join
the daily wire daily wire plus become a
member of the creme de La Grande in a
circle
you can also get the show right now in
total on Twitter at M Knowles show so
one of the things we do for the Hem
is a fake headline Friday where the oh
yeah we have a stinger that I always
forget
so plays I just talk to Mr Davis just to
irritate me it still hits that Stinger
even though I'm always going to miss it
so Mr Davies finds all these articles
most of them
are real headlines one of them is a fake
headline that he made up I have to guess
with your help and with the help of the
membrane segment room audience they
creme de La Creme which one is the fake
one so let's see first one up opinion
that gas powered car you're thinking of
buying over an electric vehicle won't be
as nice in 10 years when you have to
explain to your grandkids it's the
reason they have no clean air to breathe
there are two types of people in this
world those who only think in the moment
and those who think in the future
the problem with this headline of course
is if your grandkids God forbid had no
clean air to breathe you wouldn't have
to explain anything to them because we'd
all be goners I think that's a real
headline I think that one's true
next one devil baby born with tail horns
and Hooves
of all the hideous human malformations
ever heard of in the state the five
weeks old offspring of Charles and Sarah
I was going to say this happened in
India because sometimes India which
doesn't necessarily have the greatest uh
Healthcare you'll hear of some birth
defects and because of their religion
which has all sorts of eccentric kind of
depictions of humanity and various uh
Spiritual Beings they'll
someone will be born with a deformity
and they'll this will be taken as
something with deep spiritual meaning
but it's not Charles and Sarah are not
exactly Hindu names
tail horns and Hooves goodness gracious
I can't imagine that's real but it's so
insane I'd say maybe it's real say maybe
I took any Ukrainian Refugee to live
with my wife and me and ran off with her
after 10 days we're in love
yeah I bet there's more to this story
than just oh
oops I took in this really smoking hot
young Ukrainian lady Refugee and oh we
just what do you know we just fell in
love I want to see that guy's search
history a dad of two has run off of the
Ukrainian Refugee just 10 days after he
and his partner welcomed her into their
home yeah I kind of believe that I don't
know
wouldn't be surprised All is fair and
Love and War I guess no no I don't
really totally buy that Palestinians say
London's Big Ben was stolen from them
such lies speak to the root cause of the
israeli-palestinian conflict
I
it's hard to believe that one
but that's kind of I don't know man this
is kind of a hard week say maybe cows
lose their jobs
as milk prices drop as his hundred dairy
cows lumbered over Monday afternoon
milking former air Foster pondered his
sudden Misfortune okay I said this is
that that one's real let's say that
one's real
I'm going to say devil born with tail
horns and Hooves I know this is weird
I'm going to say this one's real
it's just because it's just so
outlandish uh
opinion the gas powered car I'm going to
say that one is real
two types of people in this world those
who only think in the moment those who
think about the future
okay this is my hold up on this one
there is a an error sometimes there are
hammers of Errors of grammar and
punctuation and spelling and so in the
capital T after the colon that raises my
eyebrows
um Palestinians say so producer Jacob is
on just a Jihad against the Palestinian
people and so I don't think he would
include one that was ridiculous about
the Palestinians if
it weren't true but this one is pretty
outlandish so I'm going to say
still leaning like kind of new I took
any Ukrainian Refugee this one I do sort
of Buy Okay so
it's between these three here I'm going
to say
I'm gonna when I follow my gut on the
grammar and punctuation and spelling
errors I'm often correct so I'm going to
say it's the opinion one that's fake but
I don't I really don't know and I let's
just see we'll see see what happens soon
as we're heading into a nice
Fourth of July weekend
oh man
there it is baby it and it's a meme of
Ben Shapiro on uh memory TV which is
really quite quite fun uh wow big one by
the skin of my teeth on that one it was
one capitalism
capitalization after a colon that got it
so it means that Palestinians believe
that Big Ben was stolen from them
what what does that mean
what I don't know what that mean
what mean what mean man Ukrainian
Refugee that poor wife kind of want to
see if there's a picture of the
Ukrainian lady that caused this poor
schlub to leave his husband his husband
his wife
devil baby born with tail and Hooves
okay well we don't have time for me to
read all of these now maybe I'll read
them after the show folks
got great news for you we are
introducing the Precision 5 razor one
handle plus one blade cartridge kit for
14.99 that is Jeremy's lowest cost for a
Razor ever and it's only for a limited
time
it's crafted with a luxurious tungsten
handle five welded steel blades and a
flipback trimmer for a close smooth
shave around Air Lines and hard to reach
places but remember
the Precision 5 is no ordinary razor
it's a sword in the battle for beliefs a
banner to wave into a new economy a
Precision instrument to force woke
companies to earn back your dollar and
stop denigrating your beliefs
it's also still a razor and it will give
you a great shave the Precision 5 is
starting at 14.99 with the price so low
it has never been easier to stop giving
your money to what corporations that
hate you join Over 125 000 men who have
ditched their woke razors and switched
to Jeremy's there's never been a better
time or Price go to Jeremy's racers.com
today
the favorite comment yesterday is from
thank you peep
or is that Thai Pete
whatever his name he says Sexy Mike I
went to the barber and got you I got my
new haircut like yours my wife says I am
crazy but I think I look fabulous so I'm
honored to hear that thank you
uh
I I think we do look fabulous Pete
um
I one time was watch Walking in
Georgetown and a guy comes up to me and
says to me
hey you don't know me but I'm
introducing myself and I just want you
to know I went to the barber last week
and showed him a picture of your hair
and say that I want to get this haircut
I'm really honored and I say this with
humility because this haircut I've had
this since I was six and it's only a
slight alteration on the haircut that I
had previously when I was five I've
never changed my haircut since then and
it's just that it's just the haircut
that guy's had in the 40s that's all it
is it's nothing really totally different
about it and you can have it too you can
have that too and now we finally arrived
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag
sponsored by pure talk at puretalk.com
select a plan and enter code Knowles KW
Las to get 50 off your first month take
it away
hello Smokey Mike this is Julia your
number one fan girl and I'm sure that
you've missed hearing my dulcet tones in
the voicemail bag
so I was having a conversation with my
brother the other day his name is also
Michael and I had told him that while
I'd never do these things I had a morbid
curiosity for tarot and uh Reiki and all
that witchy stuff uh Michael had
commented that he had a similar morbid
curiosity but more for the psychedelics
he also noted that a lot of his female
friends tend to be into the fortune
telling witchy side of that and his male
friends tended to also have a morbid
curiosity from psychedelics so Michael
my two questions to you are one do you
think that these things are two sides of
the same coin and number two do you
think that maybe one has a more feminine
side to it and the other has a more
masculine side to it thanks love to hear
your answer
yeah
yeah I do think that I think that
psychedelics are very bad things to do
because they open up spiritual portals
that are really not great and this is
the reason that the libs today promote
psychedelics as they say oh man just
puts you at one in in touch with the
universe man it really helped me
overcome you know some bad stuff man and
I know and I'm sure many people do think
that is it has helped them and I do
think that it puts you in touch with all
sorts of different entities but I don't
think they're great entities and if you
want to hear more about this you can
listen to my interview with a guy who
had taken a lot of psychedelics and what
he felt that did to him
my friends have taken psychedelics and I
had a friend he told me he said you know
one thing I love about this particular
psychedelic I took is it just it showed
me man I was just worried about so much
stuff I don't need to be worried about
you know I was I was really worried
about like sin and I had all this guilt
you know I just got rid of that I'm not
worried about hell anymore I'm not
worried about Sin and his family broke
down he left his family shortly
thereafter it
happens you know it's it's not
it's not good it's I don't want to seem
like I'm saying that everything is
demons there's a demon under every Rock
but there are demons who Crouch about
seeking the Rune of souls prowling all
over the world and psychedelics seem
even to be referenced in ancient
literature and in The Book of Enoch for
instance the Book of Enoch which is
referred to in the Bible but it's not a
canonical book of the Bible it's a kind
of mysterious old book uh it talks about
how
the demons came down and taught man how
to use Roots you know and use different
kind of plants and things like that
which I it seems seems to be a reference
to psychedelics so that's true and why
do men like the drugs while women like
the weird astrology stuff because men
are a little more Reckless especially
when it comes to their bodies than women
are men are more likely to take risks
with their bodies you know jump out of
an airplane Drive really fast and
do drugs drink too much women women
delve more into other kinds of
Temptations you know gossip astrology
complaining all this they're a little
they're just I'm not saying women sin
more than men or men sin more than women
we just are tempted toward different
vices next one
Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality again I wanted
to ask you about lobotomies and
[Music]
next one
hey Michael Alex here with a mailback
question for you love the show Regular
washer slash listener anyway I have to
actually have two questions one so you
had mentioned multiple times that RFK on
your podcast is uh very anti-second
Amendment
um I upon research that isn't true uh
his latest comments about that is the PD
is for the Second Amendment is for uh
all second member rights and he's also
for strong borders and whatnot so is
there something that you know that we
don't and then my second question is in
regards to the transgender laws that
multiple states are putting into place
Banning transgender surgeries for minors
Danny pubert blockers one-nine multiple
Rogue judges have been blocking these
laws claiming their quote unquote
unconstitutional so as conservatives how
do we get past that how do we get past
the Doom and Gloom of you pass these
laws case laws which are great but then
they're shut down by Rogue uh far left
judges so love the show Michael thanks
okay I'll take the questions in order
I'm glad that RFK has changed his tune
on a number of political issues uh but
it's a change of tune
RFK Junior has been a liberal Democrat
for his entire life he's a Kennedy and
I know that now we look at the Kennedys
on the right and we say oh Jack Kennedy
might have been a republican had he been
alive today which I don't think is true
but we say look wow the he was so much
more reasonable than the modern
Democrats which which is true but that's
just because he was living in his time
and ideas have consequences and
political movements follow those ideas
to their logical conclusions and Bobby
Kennedy is a has been a liberal Democrat
for his life I think he now sees that
one the corruption of the political
establishment is perhaps even worse than
he previously suspected the way that he
has been attacked by that establishment
for raising questions about vaccines now
for like 15 years
has probably
cemented that view
and after covet a lot of conservatives
became skeptical of vaccines in the
medical establishment so that attracted
conservatives to Bobby Kennedy Jr and
Bobby Kennedy now realizes that his most
Ardent fans are not on the left they're
on the right and so he a politician from
one of the most famous political
families in the country is probably
either playing up to that audience a
little bit more or
sincerely moving more toward their side
of the political Spectrum so great I'm
glad that he's changing on that but but
you know you you can see you can read
his past comments on these issues uh
this does represent a change as for the
judges striking down
good laws and perfectly just laws it's
very very frustrating so what we have to
do is just keep pushing again and again
and again
how many times was Roe versus Wade
upheld well it was most famously upheld
in Planned Parenthood V Casey but how
many times did Lower Court judges refer
to Roe v Wade as the settled law of the
land how many times did legal challenges
to Roe v Wade fail and reach a dead end
it just went on and on and on for 49
years for half a century
the the courts insisted no you're you
don't get to pass your pro-life laws no
you don't get to challenge rovy Wade and
then through
amazing circumstance through
Anton and Scalia going to his eternal
reward unexpectedly followed by an
improbable
his world historical figure presidential
candidate
winning the election when the Geniuses
told us 99 chance he'd lose and then
appointing three judges and Mitch
McConnell holding scalia's seat open
until you potentially got a Republican
president then Trump appoints three
judges and then the three judges worked
overall Roe v Wade we were prepared and
then opportunity came
and we were able to affect what we
wanted albeit 49 years later and I think
you're going to see that with the Trans
issue too
you just got to keep chipping away you
got to play you just gotta
play a game of determination and keep up
that moral Clarity and courage and keep
up the fight next question
hi Michael I'm hoping you can provide me
with some advice on women I'm 26 years
old and I've never had a girlfriend I'm
not really sure how to strike up a
conversation approach women or even
really a good place to meet them
I have a pretty good job I go to church
and my life is fairly well put together
so I'm not a total loser
but especially over the past few years
I've been struggling with loneliness and
was hoping you could help me out here
thank you
pal really sorry to hear about that uh
it really pains me when I hear about
people being lonely it pains me
more than almost any other issue I think
of it's not the most egregious thing
first of all everybody's lonely
sometimes uh and it's it's not worse
than say you know being murdered or
raped or you know I mean there are many
things that are
were subjectively than being lonely but
being lonely just really feels awful and
it pains me when I think of friends and
family of mine who have felt lonely at
different times it's just it's it really
really pains me and
what's bizarre about the time we're
living in is that loneliness is
something that
many many people seem to be doing more
than in in the past
you think that if everybody's doing
something you wouldn't be lonely because
when you're lonely you're the only one
doing it but but people are just so
isolated and so alienated that you might
take some comfort in that loneliness as
a group activity these days how do you
overcome that
well just here's just a little
quick little tip this is not a real
long-term answer to your when you're
feeling really really lonely crack open
a book crack open a good book reading a
book
a good book is the only activity that
you can do alone that will make you feel
less lonely but that's just that's just
a Tylenol you know that's just a little
Band-Aid how do you fix the loneliness
problem generally and specifically for
you you don't have a girlfriend or a
wife well
I would reach out to your family
say hey can you introduce me to somebody
because you're not really alone
you got some family
presumably and let's say your family's
all dead God forbid well you have a job
right you have co-workers
do you ever talk to your co-workers
maybe you don't some people don't talk
to you but I bet you talk to them a
little bit whereas hey good morning or
something like that maybe you strike up
a conversation with a co-worker maybe
it's a dude I'm not suggesting that you
you know lighten up those loafers I'm
suggesting though that any real human
connection can lead to to being able to
meet a woman and you say hey you know
what
I'm looking for a girlfriend basically
you know any cute girls around here do
you know anything does your hey your
wife you know does she have a cousin
does she have this that or the other
thing you know
it's kind of like the more you work the
more you work people think that uh you
know the way to have a great career is
to just wait for the perfect career to
come along but anyone who's ever had a
great career knows the way that you get
it is you just work all the time well
it's the same thing for social life
the way that you make really great
friends is you just
hang out with people you know and you
just strike up conversations in the
elevator you know you just talk to your
co-workers you smile a little bit and
you you ask how people are doing you're
genuinely interested in people and that
that will do it I've been really blessed
I I've had
a great love life and romantic life and
marriage life and I've had great
friendships too but it's exceedingly
rare these days and friendship I think
is rarer even than Romance
because we denigrate that now and we say
that love is love you know we say that
all love just has to be romantic or
erotic love rather than
filial love you know rather than
um
the love of God or all of these things
so you're not alone in dealing with this
problem but I my my solution for you
would would be to throw spaghetti at the
wall surely you have some family member
somewhere or surely you've got some
co-worker somewhere or surely you sit
next to someone in the church and maybe
you don't make conversation all the time
we'll just make conversations say well
wasn't that a lovely hymn and make all
what a beautiful day it is you know any
ordinary Icebreaker Small Talk kind of
language you might think it sounds silly
because no one likes small talk but the
point of small talk is not to talk about
the weather no one cares about the
weather the point of small talk is to
make a human connection and you can do
it you say you're around people
well
talk to them
all right we've got the written mailbag
coming up oh no we don't because we oh
my goodness this is so so devastating we
have
no
member block today oh and okay well you
know what I'm going to go over them
because I have one One Nail bag that I
want to get to this is from David
says I've never seen anyone make ukulele
seem as fun as you do thank you very
much kind of an old dog but I'm
interested now
how would you recommend going about
learning to play the ukulele what kind
of what kind would you suggest to start
out should I just grab a 40 instrument
off of Amazon and start strumming thanks
for all that you do yes the ukulele is
my favorite instrument probably it's the
most fun instrument
four strings it's very very easy the
standard tuning is G
starting at not at the top it's kind of
confusing because we say the top of an
instrument we're talking about the high
notes but the high notes are on the
physically on the bottom of the
instrument but anyway starting out as
you would strum it down it's G
High higher G then lower down to a c
than e then a there we go I've just
taught you how to tune your ukulele
you pull it up on YouTube how to play
You Are My Sunshine how to play
you pull up some of my videos I've done
some arrangements of little UK Tunes you
can just pull them up on Instagram just
mimic what I'm doing
pull up little chords learn your Chords
it's it's easier even than guitar and
guitars are relatively easy instrument
to learn I wouldn't spend 40 bucks I'd
spend like 60 bucks you can get Cordova
Cordova instruments are pretty pretty
good for beginner ux the soprano one is
the classic uke sound it's a little bit
small uh the concert ukulele is a little
bit bigger probably a little easier to
learn how to fret though not doesn't
quite have that fun like you know hot
bright jangly uh ukulele sound
um I had an Oscar Schmidt I still have
it an Oscar Schmidt by Washburn ukulele
which is relatively quite inexpensive I
paid 60 bucks for it
15 years ago more than 15 years ago now
um
goodness great like 21 years ago
probably I got it anyway you can get
these things you can get really
expensive yukes too but get get a cheap
one you know 100 uke 60 uke and uh
pull up some YouTube videos and start
playing it you will
you will not regret it no one's too old
and no one's too musically talentless to
learn the ukulele that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you next time
[Music]
foreign